I think I just realized my rate what is
it in the ass my ass a million dollars a
minute rate are you gonna be all Stern
about it or are you gonna play along a
little along like crazy sure rate first
minute three million I just want to say
oh over right for the type of cheeks you
got relax you're worth those cheeks I
know people I can make it happen a
million dollars too much No One's Gonna
Pay those inflated prices it's a bit
much right trying to avoid the situation
I'm not welcoming this a thousand but
I'm not trying to make it happen pay 50
000 for a butthole that's exactly the
reason why it charges so much he's
trying to get customers a thousand for
you no I pay a booty double person is
asking you I'm Outsourcing my ass no no
you're not you know why I'm still
winning because I'm actually setting a
realistic number that I'm gonna get paid
for No One's Gonna Pay 50 000 that's the
point and you guys wait I got money and
I got both